hey everyone it's dylan ephron you can
see me on flow state presented by
firestone walker
i'm here with buzzfeed to take a quiz to
see which zac efron character
i am
first things first how would your
closest friends describe you
kind curious tenacious rowdy
idealistic or slick i'm gonna go with
curious honestly if my friends called me
any of these words i'd be stoked
choose a lesser-known zac efron project
extremely wicked
shockingly evil and vile we are your
friends
charlie say cloud that awkward moment
whoa
summerland and down to earth with zac
efron i'm gonna choose
down to earth with zac efron because i
was a producer on that show
i'm pretty sure this year we're gonna be
filming a second season of it and
i can't wait for it which celebrity with
a celebrity sibling
do you want to hang out with frankie
jonas who i've met a long time ago
at disney world there's probably like a
high school musical premiere
solange knowles elizabeth olsen
beanie feldstein prince harry and jaden
smith
i'm gonna go with jaden smith everyone
knew him right out of the gates like
acting in louise with his dad and he's
grown so much and became his own man
kind of on the leading edge of
style and hip hop and everything it's
gym time oh
sorry about that it's gym time with zach
what workout
are y'all doing together squats
deadlifts
resistance training cardio pull-ups
and kettlebells it would definitely be
cardio cardio is
my thing i've took him through some
pretty tough workouts it'd be fun to
see him i don't know is that is that bad
to see
to love seeing him in pain i guess
which disney character seems like the
most fun to co-star
with in a project chad danforth
from high school musical zach or cody
from the suite life
lizzie mcguire from lizzie mcguire
phineas
from phineas and ferb rocky from shake
it up and wendy wu from wendy wu
homecoming warrior zack and cody i would
like to hang out with them
they pretty much just are up to no good
all the time causing a mess which is
pretty much what me and my friends did
pick a song to sing during karaoke
rewrite the stars
you can't stop the beat get your head in
the game
bet on it start of something new and
breaking free so i'm locking in breaking
free
for karaoke get the arm motions in there
we used to get the cds
of these songs coming out and this is
like oh this is going to be the album
for the first movie and we'd always be
stoked i'd be like in the back of my
mom's like
minivan and we'd put the cd in and
listen to the stunt the
all the high school musical songs before
they actually came out
so i i was definitely singing along in
the car back then finally choose a
hairstyle
the frosted tips the justin bieber swoop
the faux hawk the cool quaff the
oversized beanie that's fitting and the
bleached moment
i'm gonna go with the cool quaff maybe
i'll bleach my hair at some point but
not today
oh there we go i got ted from lorax
all right i like that you have a
youthful and inquisitive spirit
with enough moxie and charm to succeed
at anything you put your mind to
love it that's that's pretty cool i also
love the themes for that movie
it's all about our connection with
nature and for anyone interested i have
a new series out i partnered with
firestone walker
brewing to make flow state the series
and
essentially we just bring my friends
actors athletes out on adventures and
you can watch this
on my youtube channel it's youtube.com
dylanephron
and you can find me on instagram at
dylan.brown as well
i think you'll enjoy it and yeah give it
a watch
[Music]
you